was uh you know and when they started
making a run there are some people
Lakers are making that run they get up
to 14. even LeBron have that exchange
there are people out there that say
maybe maybe you shouldn't do that with
one of the better players in the game
what I guess what were you thinking I
don't care he's old
you know what I mean that's I was
waiting for that I was expecting him to
do that game four game five
he wanted to say something when I got my
four or five
uh we should have been saying that
earlier on
um but you know I pulled Bears
um I don't respect no one until they
come and give me 40.
so
I might pride myself on you know what I
do is defense and taking on any
challenge that's on the board